[Musique]
le 20 mai 2009 une pluie de pétal
célébit l'inauguration du centre
commercial des de Lyon un an après l'UR
tranquile s'offre donc 6 jours de
festivités pour souffler dignement sa
première bougie mais pour les
commerçants c'est surtout l'heure du
bilan après le passage de 2 millions de
visiteurs il faut être
patient à terme c'est quand même s
entreprises dans le secteur c'est 5500
étudiants 2200 logements un véritable
quartier faut laisser le temps au temps
l'avenir est devant nous le plus dur a
été passé la première année a été passée
c'est un renouveau il faut simplement
savoir attendre le boom des de liyon n'a
donc pas encore eu lieu et il a fallu
quelques mois aux commerçants pour
stabiliser leur budget aujourd'hui dans
ce magasin de sport comme dans beaucoup
d'autres boutiques du centre ce n'est
donc pas la foule des grandes enseignes
mais on se satisfait de la fidélité de
la clientèle on est à 1500 2000 clients
hebdomadaires donc c'est vraiment une
moyenne lissée sur l'ensemble de l'année
avec encore une très forte proportion de
clients F fidèles qui reviennent
systématiquement prendre des produits et
se tenir au courant de de l'évolution du
sport et en particulier de la Coupe du
monde en ce moment doucement mais
sûrement l'Heure Tranquille atteint donc
ses objectifs et compte désormais sur le
bouche à oreille pour augmenter sa
notoriété mais attend surtout le
développement du quartier il y a
beaucoup de choses qui qui qui ont
d'ailleurs tardé également à arriver
comme l'ensemble des des des ensembles
immobiliers qui sont en cours de de
livraison actuellement comme le
programme des maisons blanches et autres
également de nombreuses entreprises qui
continuent à affluer à arriver et des
bureaux qui ont également euh du mal à à
trouver preneur tout autour de nous et
qui aussi seront un levier potentiel de
de visiteurs aujourd'hui le centre
commercial des deux Lyons se tourne donc
plutôt vers l'avenir et compte notamment
sur l'arrivée prochaine du tramou pour
augmenter sa fréquentation d'ici la fin
de l'année l'ensemble des enseignes de
l'Heure Tranquille devraiit avoir ouvert
ses portes